THEY WERE RETIRING FROM
CONGRESS.
TWO HAVE WON.
WYOMING CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ
CHENEY
WILL BE THE LAST TO FACE THIS
TUESDAY.
JORDAN KLEPPER TRAVELED TO
WISCONSIN TO DISCUSS MIDTERM
ISSUES, INSTEAD WHAT HE HEARD
WAS A LOT OF CONSPIRACIES.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BE A
CONSPIRACIST OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT BUT I JUST WATCHED A MOVIE
LAST WEEK WITH ROBIN WILLIAMS IT
WAS CALLED "MAN OF THE YEAR,"
THEY HAD ELECTION FRAUD BACK
THEN.
>> IS THIS A DOCUMENTARY?
.
>> NO, IT'S JUST A MOVIE.
>> ARE THERE ANY LESSONS WE CAN
TAKE FROM MORK AND MINDY?
>> NO.
>> WHO DO YOU SEE AS THE CURRENT
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> I DON'T THINK WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE.
IF WE DO, HOPEFULLY TRUMP'S
RUNNING BEHIND THE SCENES,
KEEPING THE MILITARY ON OUR
SIDE.
>> THE RECENT ATTACK THAT TOOK
OUT THE LEADER OF THE AL QAEDA,
WHO ORDERED THE ATTACK.
>> I DON'T KNOW, IT'S ALL A
BUNCH OF THEATRICS ANYWAY.
>> YOU'RE NOT SOMEBODY WHO GIVES
INTO THEATRICS.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT DON'T WE KNOW ABOUT
9/11.
>> IT WAS ALL PLANNED.
IT CAME DOWN ON THEIR
EXPLOSIVES.
>> IT WAS AN INSIDE JOB.
>> YES, I THINK SO.
BUT I THINK BUSH KNEW IT WAS
HAPPENING.
>> REALLY?
IS BIDEN WASTING TIME THERE?
>> BIDEN DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
DOING.
>> HE RECENTLY KILLED THE HEAD
OF AL QAEDA.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S JUST THE
MADE UP NEWS STORY.
>> JUST LIKE BIN LADEN WAS
OBAMA.
>> CLARIFY WHO'S STILL ALIVE,
BIN LADEN.
>> JFK JR. IS STILL ALIVE.
>> STILL ALIVE?
>> YES.
>> I THINK JFK JR. IS GOING TO
TRY TO EXPOSE GLOBALISTS BECAUSE
THEY KILLED HIS FATHER.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS A MAGAZINE
MAGNET WHO LIVED IN NEW YORK.
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK SO.
>> ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING.
JOINING ME IS THE GREAT JORDAN
KLEPPER, CONTRIBUTOR FOR THE
DAILY SHOW.
I'M GOING TO LET YOU TALK FOR A
FEW MOMENTS WHILE I GRAB MY
BOTTLE OF ADVIL, ARE YOU EVER
SURPRISED?
I MEAN, I HAVE TO WONDER WHETHER
YOU RANK SOME OF THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, LIKE THIS
WAS THE BEST.
THIS WAS THE SECOND BEST, I
SUPPOSE IT WOULD HAPPEN BY THE
DAY THAT YOU WOULD DO THIS SORT
OF RANKING BUT, I MEAN, IT'S
JUST REMARKABLE WHAT FOLKS COME
UP WITH.
>> YEAH, I WILL SAY FOR THIS
PIECE WE WENT OUT TALKING ABOUT
THE MIDTERMS, WE THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO GET REACTIONS ON THE
OVERTURNING OF THE ROE V. WADE,
AND PEOPLE WERE JUMPING DOWN OUR
THROATS TALKING ABOUT JFK JR.,
NOT JUST ONE PERSON, MULTIPLE
PEOPLE, EVERYONE WE CAME UP TO.
IT IS SHOCKING TO US, THIS CULT
OF MAGA-ISM IS MELTING BRAINS
FULL STOP.
AND YOU TALK TO PEOPLE AND YOU
REALIZE WHEN YOU NORMALIZE THE
IDEA THAT A DEAD DICTATOR IS
AFFECTING OUR ELECTIONS,
PEOPLE'S BRAINS GET THIRSTY,
THEY START LOOKING FOR OTHER
IDEAS, AND SUDDENLY THEY
RESURRECT THE DEAD CHILD OF A
FORMER PRESIDENT, AND